dans le stress il ya une chose
intéressante c'est scientifiques
allemands ont fait une découverte ils se
sont aperçus que l'absence de stress
fait mourir beaucoup plus vite non
l'immunité mais chut l'inflation
augmente mais en fait c'est comme ça et
si vous avez deux courants
d'électricité intérieur oui il veut la
porte à toutes les maladies ils ont mis
tout chez daniel parce que c'est vrai
que pas toutes les maladies mais voilà
la porte est ouverte
qui très stressée ici si
daniel j tous noirs me suis battu
mathieu battu arrête donc quand on est
stressé on this way quand on est stressé
au contraire ça date la santé une
presse minimum sinon on est en danger
dans quel stress qui fait du bien à
l'adversité des gens qui pour se
fabriquer leur maladie intérieur à force
de ruminer des pensées négatives alors
vous dites aussi pour se défouler par
rapport à son patron pariente faudrait
compter les aiguilles moi c'est ce que
j'aurais mis dans une poupée que s'ils
font absolument qui représente le patron
tyrannique cela réduit le stress de
manière significative envie de le faire
pas du tout moi j'ai déjà acheté une
bouteille
oui j'ai lu livres poupées gonflables
[Rires]
si on n'allait pas venir quelques jours
c'était parti quand même en fusillade
aux dacquois alors vous vous le feriez
vous ah oui avec plaisir c'est qui votre
patron c'est vous
tu vas petit bouquet aux plantes comme
ça j'ai décidé de siéger en
tant que moi je vais fermer en bref
et mathieu quand tu regardais la télé le
soir je te plante ray une petite
aiguille dans le coup il a des couilles
qu'est-ce qu'il allait bien
vous les trouverez aussi à la page 142
qu'il faudrait mentir sur son âge oui
bon ça dans cinq ou logiquement ça fait
du bien oui quand on paraît disant moi
on vit dix ans de plus ah ouais mais si
on se pense plus jeunes on vit plus
vieux c'est ça donc en fait tu lâches
qui compte c'est là qu'on décide de
force et décidé d'abord kalach marion
mathieu dans mon armoire en boîte de
nuit mais que notre futur 27 ans
et venu de revoir ça va bien sûr ça
passe soit ça passe et après c'est le
matin qu'ils se rendent compte que là il
ya un peu il est pas là le matin
j'adore le beurre
10 27 ans allait fonctionner moi je
donne mon âge mais ce serait quand
j'étais plus jeune j'avais du mal à dire
j'étais assez mature j'avais du mal à
dire oui j'ai 18 ans j'ai dîné mensonge
donne un petit peu plus âgé parce que je
voulais
caritatives ou moins de 40 ans bon c'est
vrai ça passe pas du tout
c'est sympathique bernard montiel il
peut dire qu'il a dix ans de moins ça
passera non mais je mens pas je peux pas
mentir c'est marquer mais ses 64 ans et
moi que les gens au bâton
les gens ils sont 38
non mais les gens échangent entier ils
disent toujours que je fais moi mais ça
me fait plaisir et je dis dans le livre
il faut pas faire mieux aussi devrait
faire vieux c'est à dire quand on fait
mieux on prendre une attitude de vieux
et on vieillit et je veux dire on meurt
plus vite donc quelque part gilles
quelqu'un qui marche très lentement dans
la rue il parlera parisien qui marchent
vite ça change tout arrête son énergie
beaucoup plus fort gilles poupée vaudou
vous évoquez si la sexualité à
l'apparition 96 vous expliquez que la
sexualité heureuse commence à 50 ans
donc on est beaucoup ici
pour daniel
le contre exemple non mais c'est vrai
que c'est vrai alors qu'il ya plus de 50
ans ici merci merci a donc donc vous
vous avez tous une sexualité euros oui
voila je confirme alors c'est quoi
effectivement parce qu'elle l'expérience
mais surtout ce qui est passionnant ce
que j'ai découvert c'est dans la
médecine tantrique alien un temps triste
et c'est une chose étonnant c'est
l'orgasme sec c'est que sally ride et
gâteaux secs
[Applaudissements]
du petit beurre de lui détruit
des roues d'or et donc c'est quoi alors
qu'à ça c'est l'orgasme sec ça permet
d'amener le couple un ex tu as
absolument sublime quoi l'orgasme sec
donc en fait quand on sait que l'orgasme
féminin dure vingt secondes et masculin
six secondes c'est très court en dix
minutes son arrivée un premier palier et
bien à l'époque son découvert que si
l'homme maîtrise parfaitement son
éjaculation
il ya vraiment des techniques en
appuyant sur certains points
d'écartement de cuisses qui fait que
faute sociale ceux ci n'ont pensé un
pigeon mort
sans éviter de penser à des choses c'est
nice mais on peut avec simplement
car seulement
lors même avec toi des cartes en jouant
sur un écartement depuis s'appuyer à ce
que l'homme contrôle parfaitement
l'autre
quand on est en train de faire le las il
faut donc appeler une tierce personne
qui appuie
[Applaudissements]
sa puce juste là non plus
rien
et ça dure beaucoup beaucoup plus
longtemps ce qui veut dire que chez
l'homme et chez la famille et des pois
qui stimule en même temps l'excitation
ci fait qu'on arrive à une fusion du
corps de l'esprit est issue une
sexualité qu'il n'a plus rien avoir du
tout en fait on s'aperçut que quand il y
a une part de manque c'est un moteur qui
boostait libido c'est une étincelle qui
doit mais la moto
elle a un moteur de carbone
et à celle qui donne encore envie envie
à un autre beaucoup plus fort ouais et
sexualité qui a été découverte à
l'époque quand on applique ses gestes
franchement on accède à quelques jours
ce qui n'a plus rien à voir avec une
attirance vers l'autre exceptionnel
mathieu j'ai deux questions très
précises la première est ce que c'est
vrai que chez l'homme l'anus et le point
g à l'arrivée des hommes qui ont
effectivement tout cas
supplémentaires après
c'est la question
chez la femme des points alors je suis
père mais c'est quoi la réponse alors la
nuit rue parce que chez certains hommes
oui le fait qu'ils aient vu cependant
s'il ya beaucoup de courbes qui pendant
le rapport le fait de faire une
pénétration anale au niveau de la
prostate la prostate se provoque une
très forte de sens
séguin pandora est
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
donc la première question et j'ai même
vous dire quelque chose ça c'est vrai
docteur chez les homosexuels à moins de
cancers date que chez les hétérosexuels
parce qu'elle est plus souvent stimuler
vrai ou faux il est exact que dans le
cas au moins 12 éjaculations par mois on
baisse le risque de cancer de la
prostate et sodomie par jour plus le
cancer de la prostate faut qu'elle se
voit
pourtant que j'ai un ami qui a 47 ans
qui viennent bien sa vie tout sanaa
c'est une consultation et et constate
que sa libido baisse un petit peu donc
j'imagine qu'on a moins de testostérone
à cet âge là est ce qu'il faut aller
voir genre un médecin quand vous
annoncez vous parlez
bon c'est moi
[Rires]
les amis si tu t'es bon j'ai moi en vie
alors c'est vrai et je me dis est ce
qu'ils attendent au créneau log pour
remonter mon taux de testostérone à
bagnols il faut faire
l'envi chute d'abord il ya des points au
niveau du corps qui vont qui peuvent
augmenter l'an viii ouais d'autre part
il peut parfois faire un petit bilan pas
essayer de comprendre parce que
techniquement il est des raisons qui
font que la libido peut shooter c'est
qu'il bilan chez qui on va
[Rires]
tu m'achètes note bruit mais c'est un
souci quand même donc non non c'est ma
question annonay à froid vous vraiment
sympa ça c'est c'est moi qui avons quoi
mais est-ce que des
ajustements ce que je propose dans le
livre c'est de abord tenté peu verrez
que la libido remonte à fond si très
haute les noms vous verrez essayé il ya
le mode dans moi j'ai une solution
qq nouveau cac est en fête
[Rires]
côté coeur et la
raison c'est normal et les baisse de
libido surtout chez la femme c'est très
joli bidon vous mais moi c'est voilà
c'est pas c'est pas
oui j'espère que quand j'ai eu quand
james en période de règles c'est plus ça
qui me fait chaud au coeur ce qu'ils
veulent en baisse quand vous êtes par
exemple vous êtes vous êtes attiré par
quelqu'un par exemple de matthieu
delormeau ce qui vous attire alors
mathieu ne m'attire pas et je trouve
qu'il est très très très bel homme
vraiment mais non tu mates et repas
tapas côté mal tu vois que tu es à côté
vous emmerdez parfois tout à fait ce que
voulait
pas la peine de bale à bane de suite et
non
de me décrire
on avait compris oui car je suis perdue
parce que vous dites que la sexualité
heureuse commence à 50 ans sinon ça veut
dire qu'il faut coucher que dans sa
classe d'âge c'est à dire qu'en gros un
homme de 50 ans doit être avec une femme
de 50 ans parce que ce sera beaucoup
plus épanouissant alors que d'habitude
les hommes vont plus avec des filles
plus jeunes et ont finalement ce sera la
réforme il n'y a pas de règles il faut
aller là à rooney joue le ou la quête
nous
sommes d'accord d'accord mais la libido
c'est simple c'est bon ça que dans sept
à mort justement de médecine d'entrer
qui permet justement de booster ses
débits d'eau il ya des résultats
étonnants alors qui redonne une au
couple vous dites aussi que la danse a
des bienfaits mais avril précisément le
tango la danse c'est rester jeune tout à
fait parce que ça coordonne les
mouvements ouais ça donne de l'énergie
et ça fait partie des choses
essentielles qui permettent justement de
d'augmenter son énergie intérieure si
vous que je fasse un jive achevée au
baiser
mais vous un peu si on perd on est
heureux car oui moi y'a un syndrome que
j'ai dont vous parlez c'est pas chant 66
et le syndrome des fesses à mor faye oui
et ça peut lutter contre ça ça veut dire
on a les fesses qui deviennent un peu
flasque les muscles fessiers qui
s'amoindrissent et le dr ahmed
débordé le commandant gilles tu as
vraiment les façades
vous aviez les flamands oui mais elles
descendent jusqu'aux jusqu'aux genoux à
sa
façon les muscles fessiers s'amoindrit
c'est un vrai problème
alors c'est vrai que lorsqu'on reste
trop longtemps à c y et ce à un moment
donné la circulation serait pas bien les
muscles fondent et ça donne des fesses
molles à mort frais voilà merci le
résultat c'est que pour compenser on
compense avec les lombaires il ya quand
les gens ont un mal de dos très souvent
on touche les fesses elles sont molles
et amorphe d'accord pour éviter cela il
ya deux choses toutes les heures vous
contractez vous serrez les fesses 38
hockey pouvait commencer maintenant
[Rires]
je suis tout le temps debout oui bah oui
si
vous avez deux magnifiques facile si
vous touchez
pas faire le docteur
normal tu me parles salut
mais vrai
alors c'est très simple il faut en même
temps toutes les soeurs faire dit squat
ouais et ça remue scala rider via on
vous plaisir remuscler les faire
c'est bon oui il avantage se remuscler
les faits s'il y en a un autre c'est non
seulement ça enlève ce mal de dos mais
d'autre part ça va muscler en même temps
par ces squats le périnée ça et vous
savez que le périnée ses petits muscles
tous deux avec une rondelle citron
le périnée ouais patrick pyrénées
périnet le périnée c'est le petit musc
entre l'anus et le vagin et l'anus et
les bourses bas de page un psy faibli ça
donne chez l'homme des érections
instable dernier chez la femme des
orgasmes rats en musclant ce péril
justement c'est ce qu'on explique il
arrive que au bout de trois mois de
l'exercice qui prennent trois minutes
simplement à chaque fois il ya des
érections plus ferme plus tape un très
bon angle d'érection et chez la femme
des orgasmes fréquents d'ailleurs on
réédite le périnée après l'accouchement
et on a l'âge se son périnée merci à
leur dernière question vous explique
également la page soit 177 que les chats
augmenterez notre espérance de vie est
parce que l ado chars isabelle il disait
à l'endormissement par le ronron morts
ils permettent de baisser du stress en
même temps il ya un truc formidable
accès chasse et qu'ils ont la même idée
gage par le rendement des vibrations qui
ont les mêmes fréquences que certains
appareils de kiné quand les gens des
problèmes donc c'est vraiment formidable
de voir un chat chez soi
c'est pas de faire le chat série
vainqueur
[Musique]
de télé vous devrez mettre au point
pourquoi vous devriez stimuler votre
poids au cul oui ton perrine est entre
les mains d'un ferry c'est quoi au cul
c'est un point d'acupuncture entre le
pouce et l'index pour lutter contre le
stress et l'angoissé l'utiliser
formidable away qui fait que tout
simplement on peut parfois se soigner
par simple pression des doigts ya des
faits le coût des réflexes que ce soit
au niveau des contrôles alimentaires au
niveau de l'ancien lycée où on a pu la
vous appuyer la russie ça fait du bien
du bien m
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si oui vous avez une question ma petite
amie delphine et moi on est végétarien
ça permet de booster la libido est ce
que c'est vrai c'est pas votre ex
de lien entre les deux ce qui est sûr
est là ça soulève un point très
intéressant c'est qu'on s'est aperçu que
la ghréline qui leur donne de l'appétit
la ghréline la ghréline augmenter la
libido qu'est-ce que ça c'est justement
une des choses sur lequel j'insiste
beaucoup qui vient de toutes les
religions du monde c'est le jeune
séquentiel quand vous pratiquer le jeûne
séquentielle on a fait des découvertes
étonnantes pour tous et le jeune
séquentielle qui marche qu'est ce que
c'est pendant 16 heures on arrête de
manger
et c'est important parce qu'on sait que
quand on sait qu'à chaque seconde en
produit 20 millions de cellules pour
remplacer nos cellules et aux morts le
risque d'erreur de coquilles augmente
avec l'âge à vous donner lieu à des
camps quand on fait ce jeûne séquentiel
on lutte contre notre obsolescence
programmée
on laisse au corps le temps de régénérer
ne se répare et digérer c'est parier en
fait famille et une dizaine d'organes
neuf fois les régénérer ça use est
abandonnée avec ce jeune séquentiel nous
appelons quand on le pratique bien elle
va bien au n'augmente sa longévité en
bonne santé on bouscule l'unité à fond
ont fait chuter la flamme à sion on
sécrète l'hormone de croissance anti
vieillissement peut grandir et ça
augmente au saban aussi la libido et
alors on a fait la découverte qui a eu
c'est que pour que ce jeune séquentielle
marche on utilise des calories mimétique
dans des certaines plantes hier deux
minutes on pose des tisanes très
particulières qui font croire à
l'organisme à des calories sans en avoir
on fait un choix horaire
la tisane technique j'avais deux
ans ce jeune je suis jeune séquentielle
de 14 minutes
[Rires]